معنى من دونيتس كمراسل الجزيره امين
دورغامي ومن سلوفيانس مراسلنا مازن
ابراهيم اهلا بكما مجددا امين درغام هل من
جديد كشفته تلك التحقيقات بخصوص الحريق
الذي شب في القاعده الجويه في شبه جزيره
القرن
في الحقيقه حتى الان لم يصدر اي بلاغ جديد
حول ما جرى هناك
باستثناء التاكيد على ان عمليات التحقيق
تجري وان النتائج سيتم الكشف عنها في وقت
لاحق باستثناء تصريح واحد فقط قد صدر عن
مسؤول في برلمان شبه جزيره القرم قال بان
هذه الانفجارات التي
يعني جاءت جراء الحريق الذي اندلع في
قاعده العسكريه ما زالت هذه الانفجارات
متواصله حتى الان وبان عمليه اخماد الحريق
الذي شب فيها قد يحتاج يوما واحدا او
يومين السلطات كانت كما نعلم في وقت سابق
قد اكدت انها ستجلي اكثر من 2200 مدني من
سكان اربع مناطق قريبه من هذه القاعده
العسكريه واغلقت جزءا فقط من طريق تفريده
الذي يربط بين سين في روبل وجسر القرم
وسائل الاعلام روسيه كانت قد وضعت فرضيتين
لما جرى هناك احدى هذه الفرضيتين طبعا
تبقى شنه هجوم ليلي على هذه القاعده
العسكريه سواء باستخدام المسيرات بعيده
المدى ترجح تلك المصادر انه اطلقت من
منطقه اوديسا او باستهداف تلك القاعده
بصواريخ مجنحه عدا ذلك هناك طبعا
تصاعد للعمليات العسكريه بين الجانبين هذا
امر ملحوظ في منطقه البحر الاسود وسائل
الاعلام روسيه اكدت على ان الجيش الروسي
شن ضربات
وصفاتها بالكبيره وغير المسبوقه على اهداف
في اوديسا في ميكولايف وغيرها من المناطق
وقالت بانها استهدفت بالدرجه الاولى
منشات عسكريه يتم فيها تصنيع
المسيرات وايضا تجهيز المركبات الانتحاريه
هذه المصادر كانت قد تحدثت عن ان الهجوم
الذي جرى امس تم باكثر من 16 صاروخا من
طراز كاليبر اضافه الى ثمان صواريخ من
طراز اخي 22
سته صواريخ من طراز اونيكس
وصاروخ واحد فقط من طراز 59 و 32 او 32
مسيره من طراز جيران وهي النسخه الروسيه
المعدله من مسيره الشاهد الايرانيه هذا
الهجوم طبعا ينتظر بعد قليل ان تتحدث عنه
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه في بيانها اليومي
ولكن ما جرى امس وصباح اليوم ايضا ينعكس
بشكل او باخر على وضع الجبهات هنا التي
ايضا يلحظ ان هناك تصعيد في العمليات في
القصف في ايضا
الاشتباكات بين الجانبين وسط حديث عن تقدم
روسي
في محورين شمالا في محور كوبيانسكو ايضا
جنوبا في محور مارينكا قربادونيوسك طيب
ابقى معنا امين لمتابعه اخبار هذه
العمليات العسكريه من وجهه النظر
الاوكرانيه تحديدا على المحاور التي ذكرت
مازن
في الواقع حسن بدايه اوكرانيا والقياده
الاوكرانيه تنظر للاستهداف اوديسا من
زاويه اتفاقيه تصدير الحبوب هذا الكلام
كان واضحا من خلال تصريح لمستشار الرئيس
زيلنسكي الذي اعتبر بان كل ما حصل خلال
ليله امس من استهداف عبر الصواريخ اكثر من
30 صاروخا واكثر من 30 مسيره
هاجمت اوديسا ومنطقه اوديسا كان الهدف
منها اصابه صوامع ومخازن ومراكز تخزين
الحبوب وذلك في اشاره منه الى ان القوات
الروسيه تحاول القضاء كليا على كل امكانيه
للقياده الاوكرانيه للسلطات الاوكرانيه
لتصدير الحبوب لماذا هذا الامر لانه عندما
اعلنت روسيا انسحابها من هذه الاتفاقيه
كان الموقف الرسمي الاوكراني على النحو
التالي هو اشار الى ان كان ثمه اتفاقتين
الاتفاقيه الاولى وقعتها موسكو مع تركيا
والامم المتحده اتفاقيه الثانيه وقعتها
اوكرانيا مع تركيا والامم المتحده
وبانسحاب روسيه من من الشق المتعلق
باتفاقيتها قالت القياده الاوكرانيه بانها
ستستمر في محاوله تطبيق ما يتعلق بها اي
امكانيه تصدير الحبوب عبر اوديسا وفق
اتفاقيات مع شركات تامين عالميه لعلها
تنجح في اخراج القوافل البواخر من اوديسا
باتجاه تركيا هنا تعتبر القياده
الاوكرانيه بان الاستهداف المتعمد الذي
حصل في الساعات الماضيه من خلال التركيز
على ميناء اوديسون وعلى مراكز تخزين
الحبوب هدفه العسكري هو منع اوكرانيا من
استكمال او احتماليه تنفيذي اي امكانيه
لتصدير الحبوب هذا من ناحيه من ناحيه
ثانيه على مستوى المواجهه التي نشهدها ما
بين شبه جزيره القرم واوديسا من خلال
المسيرات والصواريخ
كان هنالك صمت تام من الجانب الاوكراني
فيما يتعلق بما يحصل حاليا في القاعده
العسكريه الروسيه في شبه جزيره القرم وذلك
الاعتبارات عديده قبل ساعات كان هنالك
تسريب منسوب لرئيس الاستخبارات في
اوكرانيا بان اوكرانيا لديها ضلع في
انفجار والانفجار وما حصل في هذه القاعده
ولكن سرعان ما نفت الاستخبارات هذا الامر
وذلك لاعتبار يرتبط بان احتمال الوصول الى
تلك القاعده يحتاج صواريخ بعيده المدى
وهنالك تحذير روسي سابق على لسان وزير
الدفاع قال حينها بان استخدام الصواريخ او
صواريخ ستورم شادو لاستهداف شبه جزيره
القرن سيعني عمليا توسيعا كبيرا لدائره
المواجهه وايضا اتهم حينها بان استخدام
هذه الصواريخ سيعني ضلوع امريكا ولندن
مباشره بالمواجهه وبالتالي حسن من هنا
يفهم الحذر الاوكراني في تبني اي امر
يتعلق باستهداف هذه القاعده بعجله فيما
يتعل ق بخط المواجهه المواجهات محتدمه على
اكثر من جبهه من من خاركا وصولا الى خرسون
ولكن المتغيرات ليست كبيره وان كانت موسكو
تتحدث عن تقدم في محيط
كوبيانسكاف تتحدث عن تقدم في شمال وجنوب
وايضا في عدد من المحاورشيا شكرا جزيلا لك
مازن ابراهيم من سلوفيانس وشكرا لامين
درغام الذي كان معنا من دونتس